das wäre wirklich eine sensationelle
entwicklung ein ton bzw ein lichtsignal
dass so gut wie alle krankheiten des
gehirns heilen kann
alberti dem massachusetts institute of
technology gibt es spektakuläre
forschung die das tatsächlich vermuten
lassen nie mehr depressionen kein
alzheimer mehr kein parken sind wort
krieg zum science fiction hier gibt's
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen das hier ist
ein hirnscan von einer maus langsam
verschwindet hier die plaques aus dem
gehirn die mit der alzheimer erkrankung
einher geht und das ganze wurde mit
licht erreicht topmac over vom
massachusetts institute of technology gm
erklärt was die forschenden festgestellt
haben also das licht begann mit 40 hertz
zu flackern begannen die mäuse so zu
machen irgendwas geht hier vor
und dann haben sie ältere mäuse damit
konfrontiert und nach einer stunde
passierte das gleiche
und dann haben sie es mit an alzheimer
erkrankten mäusen gemacht und nach sechs
bis sieben stunden passierte das gleiche
und danach fanden die mäuse wieder wegen
labyrinthen was sie vorher nicht mehr
konnten dass tatsächlich der absolut
sensationelle effekt der hier in diesem
fall festgestellt wurde
diese mäuse konnten danach wieder besser
denken das licht hatte alzheimer in
diesen fällen gelindert das was vorher
noch nie geschafft wurde ist hier in
diesem versuch gelungen das ganze
scheint ein effekt zu sein der mit einem
bestimmten signal im gehirn
zusammenhängt und das scheint nicht nur
für alzheimer verantwortlich zu sein
eine andere sehr interessante sache die
bei diesem experiment sehr früh heraus
gefunden wurde
man weiß dass wir 40 hertz signale in
unserem gehirn haben
da sind viele verschiedene signale da
ist ein 40 hertz signal aber niemand
wusste wofür diese signale sind eine
sache die meine kollegen sehr schnell
herausgefunden haben ist dass das eine
große bandbreite an problemen mit dem
gehirn alzheimer aber auch parkinson und
depressionen und generellen
gedächtnisverlust bei all diesen
problemen läuft irgendetwas falsch mit
dem 40 hertz signale im gehirn manchmal
ist es ganz weg manchmal läuft es auf
der falsche frequenz manchmal ist es
unterbrochen an und aus wir vermuten
dass das 40 hertz signal irgendetwas mit
dem regulieren und dem sieg
visieren des gehirns zu tun hat das
eröffnet vollkommen neue therapien
topmac over hat inzwischen auch mit
musik experimentiert für das renommierte
kronos quartett hat er inzwischen ein
eigenes 40 hertz werk komponiert die
erkenntnis vom licht und musik mit 40
hertz durch dieses stimulation startet
das gehirn schon nach zehn millisekunden
damit ein eigenes 40 hertz signal zu
produzieren und alzheimer zum beispiel
wird zumindest in diesen experimenten
gelindert was so aufregend an diesen
ergebnissen ist es lindert tatsächlich
alzheimer wenn ich diese plaques aus dem
gehirn loswerden heißt das dass die
signalwege die dadurch blockiert wurden
jetzt wieder offen sind seine idee im
umfeld der patientinnen und patienten 40
hertz signale das könnte eine therapie
hinter einer umgebung seien mit der
installation von licht und ton mit 40
hertz den häusern der leute wo die leute
die familienmitglieder alzheimer haben
das haben wir in drei oder vier fällen
gemacht und es gibt noch weitere ideen
zb eine brille die 40 hertz als infrarot
signal in die augen spielt die
konsequenz könnte tatsächlich ein
deutlicher rückgang von allen
krankheiten sein die das gehirn
betreffen wenn sich diese forschung
bestätigen menschliches gehirn versus ki
was kann künstliche intelligenz nicht
spannendes video unbedingt anklicken
anschauen und den richtig hammer
qualitäts kanal breaking lab abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran